ross there is one thing a lot of people
can get behind which is a good
old-fashioned
netflix binge and uh there's so many
shows out there but a lot of people are
returning to the gilmore girls
well and i mean it ran for seven seasons
and then it had like an ender thing and
it came back and it's a relationship
between a mother and a daughter
i've got plenty of baggage in that
department and um
now at film and tv site called screen
rants says the show
maybe 20 years old but it's still full
of parenting wisdom
uh okay this is kind of a debate though
and here to dig
into it with us is psychologist
parenting expert
friend of mine and friend of the show oh
and a gilmore girl's die hard elisa
pressman dr
hi dog man hi hi
um okay what do you feel about gilmore
girls
and mothers and daughters watching it um
gilmore girls is a great opportunity to
bond with your kid like any show where
you can connect because
it's a great story and it's cozy and
delicious and for
some younger kids not too young but
if you're watching with your younger
child you have lots of stories that you
can explain
um the good stuff is the relationship
the beautiful relationship and
connection between
lorelei and her daughter rory this stuff
that's a little
wonky but is also great for talking
through is that
that's a best friendship and sometimes
that's kind of
missing some boundaries because you
never want to feel like you
your kid has to take care of your
emotional needs or feels like they're on
equal footing with you
and you know without them you might fall
but then there's also these other
relationships like her mother
the the main the mother's mother
didn't raise her kid to be who she was
and so lorelei ran away from her and it
estranged her from her daughter and
that's a great lesson too like
don't try to raise a different kid raise
the kid you have so that you can stay
connected
do you think it's just this show that's
so interesting because i i feel like
it's
the first time we saw this kind of
relationship between a mother and
daughter like
very much the beast on television well
uh yeah
do we see it in other places too hello
um
but we saw it on television and they had
a healthy relationship do you really
think there's things we can
learn uh like bits of wisdom that they
they revealed to us
yeah i mean they bond and connect over
the things they mutually
like share like their love of binging
television
shows and watch they couldn't binge then
but they could watch movies together and
order lots of food and
just like they have these moments of
bonding even though they're very
different
and the mother never tries to turn her
daughter into someone she's not
even though her daughter is totally the
opposite of her
and maybe somebody she might have even
made fun of when she was younger that
journey
from mother and daughter being friends i
don't advocate
i it makes me nervous from my own
personal life experience
but what is the rule like what is
too friendly-friendly for mom and
daughter what are the bumper rails
because i've only got my own baggage to
like recall on what is
safe mother-daughter behavior i think
ask yourself these two questions
are my emotional needs being met by my
child
or someone else if you answer by your
child
it's just pay attention boundaries are
getting crossed
and the second thing to ask yourself is
does my child imagine
that they are the sole caretaker of my
emotions do they feel responsible for me
if they understand you have you
you know how to take care of yourself
you're going to take care of them
and you're going to teach them to take
care of themselves but they never have
to worry about taking care of you
only until you're really old um then
you've got it you're good the issue is
do they feel like
they have to take care of both
themselves and you
and are you not able to take care of
them mm-hmm that could be a burden
okay how damaging is it for the child if
they see you cry because i'm not gonna
lie i've broken down numerous times in
the last
year because of the pandemic and we're
stuck at home together and i'm drowning
well that's different that's you know
you can cry in front of your kids but
just let them know
hey this is how i'm coping i'm getting
my feelings out
but i know how to take care of myself in
this moment and in this moment i'm
feeling sad
that doesn't mean they need to take care
of you or they're scarred that means
they know
hey this is one of the feelings my mom
is having and in this household
we learn that all feelings are welcome
they're around and they're not something
to be afraid of
okay um uh
i like now that i've got you i'm so
sorry i don't even know what subject
we're on i'm so greedy
i just wish i could move in with you and
live with you and have you tell me every
little thing i'm supposed to do when i'm
supposed to do it
because everything you say makes so much
sense and also
we're all and i'm going to quote you on
this we're all just doing our best
and you have to give yourself grace
because
that's part of this too and our kids
learn that you know
when we blow it we don't beat ourselves
up
well maybe instead of drew moving in
with you could you just come back and
visit us again
that feels balanced yeah that's good
yeah okay good we found the pretty
little middle
yeah and for anyone i just remembered we
started talking about gilmore girl
so that's how we got it yep all right um
thank you dr elisa we'll have another
question for you
[Music]
asap